so this video is mainly for the beginner someone
that is just starting intermittent fasting i had
a question recently regarding the five and two um
diet which basically is what i think is the worst
intermittent fasting pattern and then
in this video i want to talk about
some really good intermittent fasting patterns
now the whole purpose of this is to achieve the
massive benefits of fasting without the negatives
like loss of muscle nutritional deficiencies so
let's start with the worst intermittent fasting
pattern it's called the five and two diet it's
also called the fast diet and this is how it
works so for five days you're gonna eat your
normal foods whatever that means and then for
two days you're gonna go on a low calorie diet
500 calories per day now to me this is not even
fasting it's really a combination between eating
junk food for five days and then for two
days you're restricting your calories
now if you're going to do two days
each day being 500 calories and it's
keto foods you're going to experience some
benefits but here is the big problem it takes
three days to actually get into ketosis so by
the time the two days are up you barely have
gotten into ketosis and if you haven't gotten the
ketosis you're gonna be suffering you're going to
be craving carbohydrates you're going to be hungry
it's going to be very very difficult but you're
going to lose some water weight initially and you
might think wow this is working it's helping me
lose weight and then you can go back to your
normal regular foods for the next five days
so from my viewpoint the five and two diet is the
absolute worst all right the next worst pattern
which is maybe slightly better than the five
and two is what's called the alternative day
fasting in which you would eat what you want
on one day and then the next day you do a 500
to 600 calorie diet so you go back and forth
and back and forth but remember it takes three
days to get into ketosis so you really are not
even scratching the surface so you may create
some benefits but number one it's not sustainable
and you're not going to even be close to achieving
the benefits that you should be achieving so let's
switch over to the best patterns so the 18 and six
where you're fasting for 18 hours and then you're
eating within a six hour window so let's say for
example your first meal is at noon and your second
meal is at 6. that would be a good 18-6 pattern
now if you want to achieve more benefits you go
to the 20 and 4 which i really like so your first
meal is at 2 and then your second meal is at six
giving you 20 hours of benefits from fasting now
if we want to take it one step further you'd want
to do one meal a day it's called omad and a lot of
people do this especially if you're over the age
of 50 with amazing amazing benefits so if you're
new to my channel i put some links down below so
you can learn how to do this correctly because
when you're doing omad you want to make sure
that you're definitely doing certain nutrients
because if you have any potential subclinical
deficiencies going into eating one meal a day
you know you could have some issues all right so
what does all this magic that happens at 18 hours
or 20 hours number one you spike growth hormone
which is anti-aging number two you increase what's
called autophagy so now you're actually tapping
into an anti-aging condition where your body is
recycling old damaged proteins and you're
starting to extend your life number three
your inflammation goes down dramatically
so if you have arthritis autoimmune issues
this is going to be very beneficial next one is
your immune system will start to improve so you
strengthen your immune system next one is you're
going to lose weight and i already mentioned
you're going to live longer by doing this and
the last two benefits which are quite huge is
this number one your cognitive benefits your focus
your memory your concentration will do better and
your mood will do better and so if you're doing
the five and two and the alternative day fasting
where you're grouchy all the time doing the
18 and 6 or 24 or omad you're going to be very
very calm you're going to feel serene you're
going to feel really good so i challenge you
to give it a chance try it out start with the
18-6 and just see how you do thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help